often seen on the front lines usually
dressed in the combat fatigues of a
military commander evgeny precaution
cultivated the image of an action man
the boss of the Wagner group of military
contractors who goes improved himself
willing and able to advance Russian
interests in a way that few others could
achieve
the power in Russia from humble
beginnings in Saint Petersburg he was a
teenage criminal serving time for
robbery and fraud then became a hot dog
salesman and then the man known as
Putin's Chef his catering company hosted
events for foreign leaders as well as
Vladimir Putin's private birthday
parties
it wasn't until 2022 the pregosian
admitted that he had founded the Wagner
private military company eight years
earlier in eastern Ukraine Hardware has
been so successful as a private military
company that it has become essentially a
franchise and so you have different uh
really very distinct organizations that
carry the same brand it was the war in
Ukraine and Wagner's role in it which
cemented pragosian's importance from
2014 Wagner contractors had reinforced
and organized the pro-russian separatist
fighters in Crimea and donbass and
Wagner played a crucial role in Russia's
2022 in Asian the handful of Russian
Battlefield successes often coming as a
result of precautions mercenaries rather
than regular Russian troops all done
with the political and financial backing
of President Putin and the Kremlin
obviously Putin has created
isn't a self-made man
he is Putin's project to create a sort
of a competitive alternative military
force in Russia to boost the
effectiveness of the regular Russian
army
his fondness for video selfies and
uncompromising rhetoric boosted his
popularity within Russia and his profile
outside of Russia but his temper
combined with a willingness to openly
berate the Russian defense Ministry
undoubtedly made him enemies an
expletive filled rant about the lack of
ammunition on the front lines was aimed
directly at the generals in Moscow and
exposed the depth of the feud between
pregosian and Putin's closest Commanders
we have a 70 shortage of ammunition
ammunition look at them
money
when pragosian ordered his fighters to
advance on Moscow it set events in
motion which made his downfall perhaps
inevitable pregosian called it a March
Putin branded it treason there was only
going to be one winner pragosian was
forced to back down
observers were surprised shocked even
when the Kremlin announced that the
Wagner boss would not face criminal
charges from the Rebellion but
pregosian's life expectancy has been the
topic of intense speculation ever since
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera
foreign